Chris Pratt as Booster Gold: It's
a dream casting for some — and a
straight-up nightmare for others. Here's the
low-down on the latest split in the DC fandom.
James Gunn has finally revealed new details
about his and Peter Safran's plans for the
future of DC Studios. The first chapter of
Safran and Gunn's rebooted era of the DCU will
be known as "Gods & Monsters." It will feature
a Gunn-penned Superman movie titled Superman:
Legacy, a Viola Davis-led Suicide
Squad spin-off show titled Waller,
a Green Lantern TV series called Lanterns,
and several other TV and film projects.
Gunn's long-awaited DC announcement predictably
caused a major stir among comic book fans,
and it's not hard to see why. Not only do these
details finally offer some insight into the
future of the DCU, but they also include the
debuts of both new and obscure DC comic book
characters. Indeed, one of the more noteworthy
projects announced by Gunn is Booster Gold,
a new HBO Max original series that will focus on
a live-action version of its eponymous superhero.
Very few details have been revealed about
the series, although Gunn did say this:
"It is basically the superhero story of
imposter syndrome on an HBO Max series."
Despite how little is actually known about Booster
Gold right now, DC fans are already engaging in an
intense debate online about whether or not one
major movie star should play the titular hero.
Earlier this month, some DC fans began calling
for Guardians of the Galaxy star Chris Pratt
to be cast as a live-action version of
Booster Gold. Over a week before James
Gunn announced the comic book character's
HBO Max series, one Twitter user said:
In the immediate hours after Gunn's DC slate
announcement, several fans began to reiterate
their desire to see Pratt play Booster Gold
in the DCU, too. On Twitter, one person wrote:
Another said:
Of course, not every DC fan thinks
Pratt is the right actor to play the
character. Following Gunn's recent
DC announcement, one person tweeted:
Another said:
All in all, it seems safe to say that DC fans
aren't in total agreement right now about whether
Pratt should actually be cast as Booster Gold.
Then again, it's worth noting that James Gunn
hasn't suggested that he's even considering
Pratt for the role. The filmmaker has said
that he'll likely end up working with members of
his Guardians of the Galaxy cast again, however,
so there's definitely a chance Pratt could show
up at some point in the Gunn-led era of the DCU.
Nevertheless, Pratt is far from the only
actor who could be chosen to take on the
lead role in Booster Gold. As a matter of
fact, some DC fans have already begun to list
other actors who they believe would be right
for the beloved DC Comics role. On Twitter,
one DC fan called for Gunn and Peter Safran to
cast Top Gun: Maverick breakout Glen Powell as
the DCU's Booster Gold. One user named
Stranger Things star Joe Keery as their
top choice to play the DC superhero, while
another suggested Jensen Ackles for the role.
Clearly, Booster Gold's casting is up in the air
right now. One thing that is for sure, however,
is that he'll likely be a superhero
unlike any other: In the comics,
Booster Gold is a man from the 25th century
who uses the era's technology to travel back
in time and become a superhero of the
past. He certainly isn't like many of
the other comic book characters that Gunn and
Safran plan to focus on in the coming years.
Whoever plays him will be given the chance to
not only get in on the ground floor of Gunn
and Safran's new DCU, but also portray one
of the franchise's most intriguing heroes.